the talk is of a lost generation youth
unemployment in spain is now running at
a record high of 56 percent many of
those at this job center in madrid say
they've given up on their chances of
finding work in their own country boys
just like I don't give us something it's
an alarming situation every day there
are more people without a job in this
and all we can do is go and look abroad
for a look at no yoki over the past
three decades the number of Spanish
migrants to Germany has risen
dramatically last year the figure was at
almost 30,000 German Labour Minister
azula fond de Lyon regards youth
unemployment as one of Europe's biggest
problems together with her Spanish
colleague Fatima banyas she signed a
deal in Madrid aimed at promoting the
mobility of young people in deutschland
Xin sought side we've got vacant
training positions in Germany at the
moment Spanish and we're very glad we've
got young spanish people who are
training in germany deutschland martin
at the madrid branch of german power
tool maker steel deuel vocational
programs of long been part of company
philosophy during their two-year
apprenticeships trainees also attend a
vocational college this approach could
prove to be one way out of hardship for
Spain's young job seekers